I want to know from Elizabeth and Andre
do you think that Jovi and Yara depend
too much on somebody else taking care of
Myla oh of course
yeah
I think they have the perfect setup
let's make this clear we not depends so
much we depend when we need the help and
Mrs Green are there for me if I will
call her I'm working and sometimes I
need to help and I'm human
I think you're a good mom no this is
like this has been over too much and I
don't want for someone think that I
depend might not want to leave my
daughter depend my daughter no she's not
but I'm working so I need my time
sometimes and that's it that's why I
don't want to have another baby because
I am not ready
I get it and I thought and you are
entitled to that feeling
she's a thousand percent entitled to
that
women today are expected to have a
full-time career
raise kids
come home cook dinner
put the kids to bed and then make their
man happy I mean it's like and I didn't
start I'm getting crazy sometimes I'm
just saying no I'm just saying that it's
not fair to women today
because you it's a double standard we
want always take up for other women and
not Lizzy I've seen that for two days
and it's starting to aggravate me you're
so smart and caring to other women but
you don't never say nothing to her you
don't know our story you don't know our
story
okay all right let's get back to Jovi
and Yara Miss Gwen you are really
emotional right now what is making you
tear up
that fight that we had was very
unnecessary
like you really yelled at me what what
did I do to deserve that talent I don't
know like you know I was getting a lot
of pressure from Yara the last time I
went to work you didn't see her the
whole time I was gone
imagine how she feels I go to work for a
month she's a mom 24 hours a day she's
alone and I want you to understand that
she really needs your help
for me
I never thought I'll let y'all down I
love being a grandma but I'm nobody's
nanny
it was a six to eight week period where
she didn't come around and it bothered
us
something you are 32 years old we have
never
had a disagreement to that extreme so
you got into an argument about mom not
helping enough let me correct that Jovi
yelled at me while I sat there and
listened in awe it's just like acting
like a brat you know what I mean
[Music]
thank you